goto barrier you can call it whatever
you want but essentially we need
protection in our country we're gonna
make it good the people of our country
want it I have never had so much support
as I have in the last week over my
stance for border security for border
control and for frankly the wall or the
barrier I have never had anything like
it in terms of calls coming in in terms
of people writing in and tweeting and
doing whatever they have to do I've
never had this much support and we've
done some things that as you know I've
been very popular all right that was
President Trump speaking earlier today
during his surprise appearance at the
White House press briefing Hannity watch
on the government shutdown a border
security we continue now with Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo
mr. secretary good to see you I see this
as a massive national security issue it
deals with relations obviously with
Mexico it's about drugs being brought
into the country human trafficking
criminals gang members some people that
have ties to terror why shouldn't we all
view this as a national security issue
well sure thanks for having me on
tonight we should we should all be very
serious about this I've been the CIA
director and now the Secretary of State
this has enormous national security
implications border security is an
important part of American sovereignty
and keeping Americans safe there is a
central role to make sure that we know
who's coming in and what is coming into
our country and president Trump is doing
the right thing and making sure we
understand what's moving across that
border and we do so with enough border
security so we have confidence and we
can do this on behalf of the American
people we've been able to apprehend
3,700 people that we've identified as
having ties to terror there's lots of
risks associated the narcotics risk
itself has enormous implications for
people inside the United States there
are lots of things that come across that
southern border that we need to get
control of when President Trump is too
to make that happen it includes the rest
that we have terrorists come across that
border we're talking about Central
America but you've had a pretty busy
year we have the talks with North Korea
talk about denuclearization of the
Korean Peninsula
we have issues now with China we also
have issues with the Middle East new
alliances opportunities hopefully
emerging certainly with with Israel with
the Iranian deal being being drawn back
where do you see on the world stage
where is America different now because I
don't think the president gets a lot of
credit for a lot of progress around the
world
Oh Shawn we have we have made
fundamental changes in American foreign
policy that enormous ly benefit the
American people I could I could tick
through the same lists of places that
you spoke about the previous
administration had decided that the
world's largest state-sponsored terror
was the partner in the Middle East Iran
we fundamentally flipped that and we
know that that is a real threat to the
world and to America and so we have
developed relationships with Arab
countries in Israel we've brought them
together to develop a coalition to keep
Americans safe from things going on in
the Middle East you spoke first I think
about North Korea
lots of work that left is left to be
done but I'm confident to the next short
period of time president Trump and
Chairman Kim will get the chance to meet
again and truly create a much better
safer America with less threat of not
only nuclear weapons being launched at
us but nuclear proliferation as well
these are real risks and real changes
from the previous administration's
policies all right let's talk
specifically about North Korea so the
president's been hinting and saying that
there's going to be another meeting with
Kim jong-un will that be about and will
there be the potential at that meeting
of the denuclearization of the entire
peninsula obviously missiles aren't
being fired remains have been sent back
hostages have been released so a lot of
progress is this where you might close
that deal oh sure I'd be surprised if we
get all the way home in this meeting
although it would be fantastic if we did
I don't want to tell you exactly what
our negotiating strategy is but suffice
it to say I think we have set the
condition
where we can make a real progress when
chairman Kim and president Trump meet
and take down the threat to the United
States and to the world that has been
you know frankly holding America hostage
for so long in North Korea it'll be good
for South Korea it'll be good for Japan
it'll be good for all of the world the
putting aside the Khashoggi incident
there seem to be an emerging new
alliance against Iranian hegemony and
that would be the United States our
closest allies Israel the Saudis
Egyptians Jordanians up till recently
the Emirates against the Iranians do you
see an opportunity historic opportunity
where these alliances could lead to a
peace that nobody could even have been
thinking about ten years ago the shona
undoubtedly we have set the conditions
in the Middle East where these countries
are now working together across multiple
fronts you saw the president's
announcement about our withdrawal from
Syria we're still going to be able to
effectively with those partners counter
the threat from Isis in the region and
we'll do it without those 2,000 soldiers
on the ground we we haven't changed our
policy about continuing to make sure
that there is no Isis resurgence and
we're just going to do in a way that is
smarter and better and we can do that
because of the alliances the president
Trump has built all right let's talk
about China in the sense they've had a
massive military buildup but your State
Department issued a warning to Americans
traveling to China that in fact they
could issue exit bans preventing
Americans from leaving what's the status
so shown we didn't change the level of
the warning there in China we did change
some of the language we we do our best
here to constantly review things that
might happen to Americans who are
traveling abroad we saw what happened
with the American there in Russia our
job is to always have American Americans
safe who are traveling and we wanted to
let them know that there have been more
risks from what China has done in terms
of folks traveling there and not being
permitted to return we just want to make
them aware of that and I'm hopeful that
we got the language just right so
Americans will understand the risk but
still travel there when it's appropriate
to talk about the latest in terms of the
relationships with Russia obviously a
hostile regime obviously a hostile actor
and
Damir Putin not only the United States
but other countries have experienced
their cyber warfare if you will or their
desire to create chaos in other
countries but if you can address that
and also their support of the Iranians
their influence in Syria and do you see
an Iranian Russia Syrian alliance that
would worry you I am concerned about
that and frankly the Russians behavior
has has not been good but this
administration has been very serious
responding to that whether it was the
strike that presidents the strikes the
presidents taken in Syria those were in
Syria but the Russians were all around
it our effort with respect to what the
Russians did in in skorpa the sanctions
we put on Russian oligarchs who have
threatened America and American
interests those are real responses we've
done that John at the same time that
we're trying to find space where we can
work with them trying to find
opportunities where the Russians and
American interests overlap even if our
value sets do not so that we can work
together against some of these most
difficult problems it's been tough and
Vladimir Putin has not cooperated but
we're still trying to find a place to do
that president has some critics as it
relates to saying that he wants to
withdraw from Syria and Afghanistan is
there a timetable or will it be based on
the situation on the ground president's
always been very clear that he wanted to
get our soldiers back home and Syria
he's made that decision and we are
working in that direction that that
decision is done and we will withdraw
from Syria the timeline will be
consistent with what we can do to make
sure that our soldiers are safe that we
continue the counter Isis campaign that
we do all that we can to keep the
coalition against Iran together those
are also things that the president's
made very clear he was going to do when
he visited Iraq now goodness a week ago
he made very clear that those were
things that were also important so we
will manage those threats to America but
we'll do so without a couple thousand
folks on the ground in Syria I wouldn't
even venture a guess howmany frequent
flyer miles you have as a result of just
one year we've been friends a long time
I know how hard you're working and how
much success is
happening on the world stage secretary
Pompeo thanks for joining us Sean thank
you very much have a good evening